hey so just a little info about this
collection now we still get hit with a
lot of copyright claim sadly and we do
fight them but we have to fight them
slowly or else we might get a strike and
such and one of the groups that comes
after us a lot is sadly Studio Ghibli in
Japan the Japan version I don't think
the American one comes after us so we
haven't posted is nice embers of the
Studio Ghibli collection but we're
posting it here because we figure if
it's one video that gets hit that's a
giant collection of them that we can
fight easier than a ton of them but what
we did that month is that we had Studio
Ghibli and then we have like kind of
these other Disney films I didn't review
that people want me to review so we're
gonna split them up into two and this is
the collection of just the Studio Ghibli
films and we'll have the other ones that
were in this month in another collection
I'd just be safe if this one does get
hit you can still watch the other ones
while we fight that so with that said
take a look and enjoy if you were to ask
a random person on the street who hyoe
Miyazaki was chances are they wouldn't
know but if you were to ask a movie buff
anyone online or pretty much any person
from Japan everyone would tell you that
he is the animation champion of the
world only in the past 10-15 years has
he finally started to get credit in
America
allowing our audiences to see tons and
tons of his genius work but it turns out
he's not the only one turning out
Miyazaki material his animation company
Studio Ghibli has also been turning out
timeless classic after timeless classic
again only starting to get recognition
in America in the past 10-15 years and
who do we have to thank for all this
imagination being shown to us that's
right the Big D or more specifically
John Lasseter who's friends with Hayao
Miyazaki and promised to get as much of
his work to our audiences as possible
the result was the majority of the
studio's films being re-released and
redubbed
in America but they didn't just half-ass
it they went out of their way to get the
best talent possible but that sound
people the best translators and of
course the best actors it only figures
that Disney another great leader and
animation imagination would be the
people to introduce us to not only such
wonderful artwork
such fantastic stories so this Disney
Center every single day of the month I
am gonna be looking at one of the film's
from Miyazaki or Miyazaki Studio the one
catches that it has to have been
re-released by Disney and read up by
them because hey it is Disney Center
now there's only one problem with that
there's not enough films to fill out the
entire month so what am I gonna do
I'm gonna go back to all the films that
people requested but I never got around
to
that's right The Nightmare Before
Christmas is the Dick Tracy's hell I'll
even go over the ones I did a view log
of already but people seem to want to
see the Disney Center version of it and
a some time has gone by maybe some of
the opinions have changed so every other
day it's a Studio Ghibli film and the
other half of the days it's gonna be one
of the Disney classics but he'll even
that's not enough so I'm gonna give in
to peer pressure and also do a V log
series on one that'd be giving a lot of
requests to do for awhile that's right
both my brother and I are gonna be doing
a veal OGG series of gravity falls right
along with Disney cember every single
day of the month it'll be the most
ambitious Disney cember yet you'll be
vomiting rainbows a week after watching
them there's a lot of imagination a lot
of great characters a lot of great
stories hell there's just a lot of
greatness to get there so sit back
everybody this is Disney cember the
Studio Ghibli overlook classics and
gravity falls edition
let's start with a film that wasn't
technically studio ghibli when they came
out but they still marketed under the
name and Disney pick it up anyway so I
think it counts
nossek on the valley of the wind a film
surely not to be ignored this was only
director Miyazaki second film and
already it was a gigantic epic the story
centers around the princess yeah get
used to seeing those I think Ghibli
might be the only studio that actually
uses princesses more than Disney who
lives in an apocalyptic future actually
one of the nicer apocalyptic futures
very green lots of mountains nice
scenery well at least in this part of
the world other parts of the world
there's nothing but war a-brewin
everyone's attacking everyone trying to
find old monsters and creatures to
destroy one another when those warring
countries find the valley of the wind
they see an opportunity to use their
land and their resources to their
advantage Nausicaa after discovering the
death of her father peacefully tries to
find a way to save everybody and not
cause any more bloodshed along the way
comes across a boy who's on the other
side and asks her to join his quest but
she doesn't want to be on any one side
she just wants war to leave and no more
people to die no more people or bugs yes
in this futuristic world there's also
giant monsters that look like bugs l
even the plains Catholic white buttons
but you can't cool will you think about
it you assume all birds are gone in this
world so their planes wouldn't really
look like birds like ours instead they
would look like insects
Gavin II know but nevertheless Nausicaa
doesn't want anything living to perish
so she goes back and forth between every
single side imaginable trying to find
the peaceful route for only a second
film it's one hell of an ambitious
project it tries to throw so much of you
and for the most part it pays off pretty
well you very easily understand the
conflict of every single character and
every single character does have a
conflict it's a lot of fun just seeing
them work off each other trying to
figure out strategies what to do next
everything is always in a huge rush
something like that can usually be a
little too busy and distracting but the
characters are strong enough to pull it
through at first I thought was kind of
weird that Nausicaa would flip-flop back
and forth between sort of this crying
sad emotional person to the sudden sword
wheeling badass that always seems to
have a plan but when you see what it's
all building up to in the end
yeah does kind of make sense it's kind
of like a peaceful person who knows how
to fight but never really wants to fight
because he doesn't want to see anyone
her so when she does have to do it for
her rage gets the best of her she feels
an incredible amount of guilt but that
said I love the fact that she always has
a plan I mean always our ship is going
down you go this way I'll go that way
I'll jump up here and do this thing
Kingdom being overthrown I'll go this
way you go this way
well rendezvous after we do the huge big
gigantic thing she isn't just kicking a
little bit of ass and that's it she
always has a strategy and she comes up
with him so fast
she's a lot of fun to watch she also has
a real good supporting cast voice actors
like Patrick Stewart and Shia LaBeouf
really add a lot of credibility yeah I
know what you're thinking Shia LeBoeuf
at credibility
well yeah say what you will about
personal life in the transformer movies
but I don't think he's that bad an actor
and I think he finds just the right mix
in this role angry and vengeful but
still looking for the right thing to do
if I did have a problem with this film
though I would actually say that as good
as the characters are I could have used
just a little bit more that is to say if
a story like this really want to have
the biggest impact it probably should
have been tunes I mean when I say they
throw a lot at you and it is constantly
on the move that's not to say they don't
have they're slower moments to just be
characters they do and they're done well
but for the giant climax this film is
trying to build up at the end I felt I
really want to know these people a touch
more
for example the villain play by uma
Thurman and their second-in-command seem
to have this kind of playful banter
where they almost hope the other would
die but they also kind of respect the
strategy of the other a part of me
really want to know more about that but
it's a big animated epic and you can
only fit into two hours so a lot of that
stuff has to be cut and I'm sure there
was more stuff this is based on a manga
I get the feeling they went into even
more detail about these people it's not
that the film needs to be longer it
already feels like a decent length I
just felt like I really want to be on
these characters side more than what I
was which is to say I didn't want to see
them perish
I didn't feel the entire weight of the
film the way I think it wanted me to
feel it maybe one or two less scenes of
traveling and shouting orders replaced
with a little bit more of natural
talking we've done it but that really is
a bit of a nitpick it's still very large
and scale I'm very impressive to look at
and I want to know what it's all gonna
to have they been able to explore a
little bit more I think this could have
been on par with say the Lord of Rings
movies but as is it's still pretty damn
impressive
it's so cool seeing where all of these
Miyazaki tropes started the technology
the monsters the love of nature his
thumbprint is all over it and it's even
more impressive when do you think no
computers were used on it either I mean
look at this this looks like something
that could be animated to date great
backgrounds great environment great
atmosphere great characters great story
what else can you say Nasik on the
valley of the wind is just great go take
a rent and see for yourself
[Music]
the awesomeness of castle in the sky can
be summed up right in the very opening
ships are sewing through the air a young
girl falls out a boy discovers her and
suddenly a glowing crystal causes her to
slowly but surely float down to the
ground while it chanting music is played
yep that's the movie in a nutshell and I
mean that in a very positive way castle
in the sky has all the ambitious
adventure of a kids film that you
remember watching in the 80s the ones
that had a touch of an edge but mostly a
very timeless endearing feel to them the
ones like Return to Oz or labyrinth the
ones that still seem to hold up after so
many years for the most part there's no
data but copies in this though may be
the head of that robot could anyway the
film starts off exactly like I said a
girl falling to the ground and a boy
discovers her the boy's name is pazzo
and the girl's name is cheetah voiced by
Anna Paquin and james van der beek he
misses her back to health as she admit
that she's being chased by some
evildoers the kind that know that she is
the key to some sort of mystical
something or other again variaties
fantasy quite coincidentally pazzo has
been looking for that something or other
a floating city known as Laputa some
believe it's been destroyed others say
it never existed but of course our young
heroes are destined to discover it along
the way they come across some
treacherous air pirates with their
leader voiced by Cloris Leachman who in
my opinion can do no wrong she once
again plays up both the comedy and the
awesomeness of this character being both
goofy and badass at the same time the
villains chasing them are led by mark
hamil who if you know his voiceover work
once again gives a deviously delicious
performance dragging out his lines and
constantly making you question does he
have a British accent or not once again
not only does the artwork in this movie
show a lot of patience and a lot of
passion but the creativity is just
wonderful I feel like I'm watching an
extended version of the timeless Disney
Afternoon shows kind of like ducktales
meets tailspin duck tales been with
people but whatever you call it it's a
ton of fun the dubbing is once again
very well done with the main characters
voices displaying the why
wimzie and the side characters being
goofy and memorable for whatever reason
I especially like the lighting in this
film too particularly the day versus
night I'm always a sucker for night
shots to have that warm glow from a
building and something about Miyazaki
skies are always just so blue you can
get lost in them somehow I don't know
what color is choosing or what palette
he has but they're always just
incredible you want to fly through these
guys every time you see you if I had to
nitpick anything wrong I guess I could
say that maybe James Van Der Beek sounds
a touch too old to be playing this part
but then again you can't quite figure
out the boys age maybe just as voice is
changing everything else in this movie
is classic Miyazaki a lot of focus on
the tentacles and how they work a lot of
using machinery but also this very high
respect for plant life there's something
so cool about seeing those rustic robots
and yet having green grow on them in
strange way I think that almost sums up
Miyazaki's work a perfect combination of
advanced technology that's also kind of
old kind of new but always has a good
mix of nature in there too the Pirates
especially are just so likable I don't
know what it is about them there's just
so much energy and they're so goofy and
they have such an awesome leader it's
pretty hard not to wish you could be a
part of this group it has a lot of the
pretty imagery I love the nice colors
and a lot of the imagination that you
usually associated with his work it's
hard to know what else to say about it I
mean I don't know if it's gonna be
breaking any big barriers necessarily at
least none that I know of but as these
general fantasies go once that mix
technology with great characters and a
gripping story with lots of nature and
excitement and romance and just all that
good stuff you've grown to love this one
mixes them up pretty good take flight
and discover for yourself
[Music]
whenever there's a discussion about the
most powerful animated films like no
fairytales no magic just pure raw adult
emotion grave of the fireflies is
usually brought up a lot of people
consider it a good segue who see
animation as just kids stuff something
that can't be taken seriously by adults
so when I heard that I got really
excited and I sort of got this idea of
what it was gonna be like and what it
was gonna be about I saw this film
around the same time I saw Saving
Private Ryan on the big screen and I had
an idea what it was gonna be
Oh war is bad people throwing up their
hands saying why oh the no good of
violence and so on and so forth
but what I got was something very very
different I knew it was gonna be more
focused on the family end but not quite
in the way they depicted it I don't even
see it as really a war movie I see it
more as a battle between pride and
sanity between love and
self-preservation so it kind of confused
me when I was younger cuz I kept
thinking I was going to see some serve
anti-war film and I thought that's not
really what I got I didn't dislike it I
knew it was good I just didn't quite
know what to clarify it as what to
accept it as now that I'm older that's
one of the things I liked the most about
it it doesn't seem anti-war or pro war
it's just a boy and his sister trying to
figure out what's the most important you
know the films gonna be grim when you
see the death of our main character
being reunited with the spirit of his
younger sister well we know this doesn't
end happily we can only go up from here
the two have a flash bag as they roam
the spirit world of how they got to
where they are the boy's name is SATA
and the girl is Cisco they're in the
final days of world war ii but you
wouldn't know it with all the bombings
are still going on their fathers in the
war and their mother is suddenly killed
from one of the bombings the two decided
to go live with the distant aunt but she
starts to get a little on their nerves
claiming they aren't working hard enough
for the food that she's preparing and
having a pretty understandable breakdown
every once in a while for the situation
that she's been put in unsatisfied with
the living situation sienta decides to
take his sister and live on their own
believing he's totally capable of doing
so trying to claim his independence
slowly but surely he discovers that they
can't serve
on their own but he's too proud and too
determined to see the truth and lives in
a horrible state of denial thinking they
if he tries harder and sticks to his
independence they can come out of this
okay but reality starts to set in and
options start become fewer and fewer
always thinking salvation is just a day
away he continues to try as best living
on his own laws world crumbles the
artistic style in this movies not trying
to be so much prettier showing off as
much as trying to be more realistic they
still move like animate characters but
it's not trying to do any big kicks or
flips or any weird angles most of the
shots keep very still and just let the
emotion of the animation carry it
through as well as the voice acting
which is dubbed over pretty well I
personally grew up with a subtitle
version and prefer that one a bit more
but the dub is still very well done
there's a lot of different ways you can
look at this movie on the one hand you
can see the boy as a terrible character
not only is he laying himself start to
death be slaying his sister's start to
death as well but I think because they
choose to do this age it makes us
suddenly understand what he's trying to
accomplish I think a lot of growing
people at that age can become incredibly
delusional and that may be part of the
focus of the story is not to try and
grow up too fast
and to appreciate what you have and who
you have while you still have them well
many people see it as an anti-war film I
suppose you can see it as that way my
thought is that this can take place over
any disaster it could happen after a
tornado a tsunami and earthquake or yes
even a war the focus is on the boy who
doesn't realize how far he's being
pushed and that there's no crime and
accepting failure or asking for help
part of what makes it work is that the
boy himself is not a mean character a
lot of people that have a lot of pride
they usually just throw into the jerk
category oh there's nothing good about
them they're just too full of themselves
and think they can do stuff that's
totally delusional but this kids a
likable kid his dad is a fighter and he
wants to do the same thing he wants to
be the big supporter a lot of young
people were under that delusion during
World War two if you're failing it just
means you're not trying hard enough
fight harder fight harder I think
there's this sense of losing one's on or
if you accept defeat which is fitting as
we CCA to witness the surrender of Japan
and he's furious by it he doesn't care
that the war is over
he's just torn apart
they actually lost it's a film that
takes an angle that many films like this
don't take not the family element
there's a lot of movies that do that but
the coming-of-age element of knowing
when to declare your independence and
when not to and that the consequences
can be greater than you ever could have
imagined
for someone who was expecting more the
Saving Private Ryan route where there's
gonna be a lot of dead bodies and a lot
of gore and a lot of obvious symbolism I
was really blown away that the
emotionally gripping and tormenting
parts of this movie are the simple
choices that they make and how easily
things could have been fixed if he just
swallowed his pride as a young man
watching this I don't know if I was
really ready to accept that or at least
I didn't know how to accept it
maybe in that way it was more ahead of
its time an adult than I thought you
have to have a real understanding of
what misguided pride can do and what the
non acceptance of failure can be capable
of the honorable route is not always the
winning route and that's a tough thing
not just for people growing up to learn
but for straight-up grown-ups to learn
it gets a little better and a little
more heartbreaking every single time I
see it and maybe that's because I feel
like I understand it have been more
every time I see it but again one of the
great things is you could look at at a
totally different way maybe it's about
respecting your elders maybe there is no
right or wrong maybe it's all about the
war maybe it's all about the
consequences of war anyone can look at
and draw their own conclusion what is
concrete about the film is that you look
at these two characters and want them to
make it through even though you're told
at the very beginning that they're not
going to make it through this makes it
all the more heartbreaking as you watch
whatever age you are it's an important
film to check out it's unlike any other
film of its kind and deserves all the
praise that it gets
[Music]
it's the iconic my neighbor totoro
a character so famous they's actually
the icon for studio ghibli a big hit in
Japan and even growing a cult following
in America the hype and good talk around
this movie is so big that a lot of
people Edgeley end up kind of not liking
it and I can see why it's built up so
much and this image is so popular that
anyone going in thinking they're gonna
see the spectacular big story is
probably gonna be really disappointed
luckily when I went in I had no
expectations whatsoever I've just got it
from a friend saying hey this is a good
movie check it out I did and that's
pretty much what I thought - it was a
good movie not great I don't think it's
supposed to be great I think it's
supposed to be just a fun little flick
why there's such an explosion over it I
don't know maybe people just like the
sort of smaller flicks and want to get
it more attention to a point where it's
actually exploded into this giant
franchise it's kind of like how a
Christmas story has but for what it is I
like it fine the stories about a family
that moves into a new home there's a
father a mother and two little daughters
played by the Fanning sisters what they
discover something very interesting
about this home apparently there's
spirits all over the place in any other
movie this would probably be a scary
thing but the family just kind of
accepts it and says hi sometimes the
spirits say hi back but most the time
they just keep in hiding and wouldn't
you know it one of them is a giant koala
cat turu thing known as Totoro he
doesn't exactly do much he just kind of
sleeps takes the bus
he can fly that's kind of cool and he
has absolutely no dialogue outside of
one or two roars and that's about it
really that's the movie it's just sort
of watching these girls interact with
the spirit and them getting used to
moving to a new location and or whatever
reason it kind of works and don't get me
wrong
there's still some incredible imagery in
this the backgrounds are wonderful
there's this cat bus thing that's now
become
world-famous and a lot of flying scenes
are very nice if you were to ask me what
happens scene by scene like an order of
the story I couldn't tell you that is to
say stuff does happen you see them
trying to get used to being this plays
and interacting with boys and so on so
forth but the story's not really the
focus the focus is more character an
atmosphere the casting of the Fanning
sisters was a very clever call as they
weren't very naturally off each other
they don't act like Co actors or even
just friends they feel like sisters
something about that camaraderie and the
way to work off each other it's pretty
solid the rest of the voice acting is
pretty good too so not a ton is required
of it it's still pretty effective it's
kind of like spending a really laid-back
Sunday outside with some friends maybe
coming across a weird animal trying to
interact with it playing around getting
dirty coming home and going to sleep
that's kind of the movie but again
that's kind of childhood - isn't it kind
of those fun summer days where you could
just sort of do whatever you want you're
out of school and I don't know that's
how I see this movie it's just kind of a
really fun yet laid-back summer when
you're a little kid
there's fun music and goofiness but
there's also a lot of quiet moments of
just a character looking at another
character or just taking the other end
now there's something actually really
charming about it no no maybe that's
kind of a strange fascination with the
film that absolutely nothing can happen
on screen and yet you're still kind of
sucked into it there's a whole scene
where one of the sisters just sits on
top of Totoro and that's it there's a
nursery where the other sister just
waits for a bus with Totoro and that's
it yet something about the way it's
paced and animated and delivered it
feels very alive somehow you don't feel
like you're being manipulated or that
this is lazy you look like you're
watching something kind of cool
not spectacular but kind of cool and the
film allows you to take in this small
bit of wonder well it's not big it still
allows you to take in the full amount
you soak in the scene you remember the
feelings you remember the ex
freshens if stuff like that doesn't do
it for you and you're looking for
something that's a lot more story based
then you're probably not gonna have a
good time with this granted there is a
dilemma in the last third of the film
but it almost feels a little forced and
in some ways not needed like the film
just needed some kind of climax that's
nowhere near so contrived that ruins
anything you still want to see
everything turn out okay and stick with
these characters oh yeah don't expect a
lot of action or a lot of wonder or a
lot of story but just expect a small
amount to be satisfied I think that's
part of the charm of Miyazaki's films
you had this art form of animation
anything you can draw can suddenly exist
and yet they use it to tell the story of
only a few fantastical things and focus
more on the human characters something
about keeping it so minimal actually
makes you appreciate what's on screen
even more at least from my point of view
I don't know I even heard there's like
any kind of backlash for this film but
I've definitely heard of people that
watched it and just didn't get what it
was all about and I can understand that
there is so much build-up for this movie
the image is shown all over the place
hell it's even in Toy Story if you're
looking for more of a relaxed film that
you can pop in and just sort of enjoy
the atmosphere of you'll find it to be
pretty charming pretty creative and just
the right amount of entertaining I
personally don't see it as one of my
favorites I don't even know if I put in
one of Miyazaki's top five but it's
still good and there's a lot of effort
that's put into it it's small it's
simple who says there's anything wrong
with that
[Music]
everybody's gonna have a film that just
connects with them for some reason they
can't entirely explain for many that
movie was my neighbor totoro for me it's
Kiki's Delivery Service in a sense
they're very similar not a lot of story
not a lot of action just sort of a
laid-back set up with a touch of the
supernatural but for some reason this
really grabbed me and hooked me a lot
more than my neighbor totoro did and
that's especially impressive when you're
given the age that I saw it I was a
junior in high school when I first saw
this and I didn't want to see any of
this prissy stuff what a little bitch
with a big bow flying around not casting
spells but instead delivering bread to
people come on give her a machine gun or
something I'm a stupid high schooler
that's what I want to see but even with
that prejudice going in I saw this on TV
and surprisingly kept watching it even
for his cutesy and simple as it was
something about it just really drew me
into it to a point where at the end I
found myself really loving it the story
centers around Kiki of course played by
Kirsten Dunst she's excited because
she's at the age where witches can set
off on their own and try to find their
own identity they leave the family find
a place to live and try to see if they
can work in the real world she flies to
a town far away where she eventually
gets a job as a delivery girl
accompanied by her snarky cat voiced by
Phil Hartman the movie just follows her
around as she does sort of typical girly
things make deliveries chat it up with
friends talk about boys all that good
stuff and once again that's kind of all
there is to it just watching the simple
life of this little witch I really love
how Miyazaki's worlds are just so
accepting of these fantastic
supernatural elements they just live in
a world where witches are normal okay
whatever
there's a whit flying around hi how you
doing at the same time they still ask
your questions and want to know things
about her it gives a very clear
understanding of how they're accepted in
this world kirsten dunst is absolutely
perfect as Kiki
never feels forced it never feels like
she's playing the role too young or too
old it seems like the perfect age all
the side actors are great too the only
one I might have an issue with is Phil
Hartman as the cat I don't know it's not
bad but there's always something about
his cynical sense of humor where you're
not sure if he's really taking the role
seriously or not a lot of people can
find that even funnier but I don't know
sometimes it seems a touch of pudding to
me but then again that's also kind of
the character so I'm up in the air about
it but it doesn't distract too much for
me I can see how people would enjoy him
your room is nice but let's take your
mother's you're no help if I did have a
problem it's once again kind of like my
neighbor totoro there's kind of a forest
climax at the end this one's even bigger
than my neighbor totoro because it's
like this great big action scene and on
the one hand yeah you have a character
that can fly around it kind of makes
sense to do something a little
action-oriented but it just kind of
comes out of the blue it's kind of
different from the rest of the feel of
the movie and I don't know it's not bad
I guess I just sort of feel like
couldn't you cut that out and leave sort
of the very low-key tone alone but then
again doesn't every movie kind of need
an ending and a third act to build some
conflict and drama I don't know there
must have been some other way to do this
it's not terrible it's just a touch
unfitting but the rest of the film like
I said it's just enjoying the very
simple but likeable life of this little
girl you get to know the town you get to
know the neighbors and the side
characters and of course she gets to fly
around and the flying shots are
wonderful I don't know what it is but
something about the way Japanese
animation does flying scenes that
they're very well done there's not even
a CG used here and yet somehow you
really feel like she's in the air
something about the angles and the
movement they get I'm not sure what the
magic formula is but they got it nailed
somehow the anime is so that you feel
the weight of the character that's
actually flying and I don't know how you
do that but they found a way look at how
she drops here you feel the gravity in
that scene
like I said I'm not entirely sure why I
like this one more than my neighbor
totoro but something about it really did
grab me maybe it's because she does
explore a little bit more and she does
have to travel but at the same time you
get an idea about how this world works
and how people accept witches and yeah
you almost got a while live in this
world it seems so simple and relaxed
that you really enjoy being there you
kind of want to sit with this artist and
talk about what she's painting you can't
help this old lady bake something for
her granddaughter's birthday and you
really get bummed out when the daughter
actually doesn't like the thing that she
begs and you're just like come on yes
boy a little brat what's wrong with you
she worked really hard for that you
ungrateful little bitch you see what I
mean somehow I get really wrapped up in
these tiny little problems that's going
on in this town and with this one girl
but screw it I'm with her it's like just
sitting through a little bit of real
life and yet somehow with this
supernatural character it's such a weird
combo but for whatever reason it really
works I can't even think of any other
words to describe it except delightful
it's just friggin delightful I love
being with these people I love being in
this town I love flying around it and I
like seeing it from the point of view of
this wide-eyed adventurous innocent
she's just friggin adorable I love it
when she gets a package delivered I love
it when she gives that one chef a hug
for making that little delivery sign out
of bread I love it when she laughs well
they almost got killed writing that
weird fan bike thing with that weird
inventor boy and just I can't help it
it's just irresistible so like I said if
you're not a fan of these kind of
stories that well don't have much of a
story and mostly just atmosphere and
character you probably won't get that
sucked in but me I enjoyed every minute
of it
I love that they feel they didn't have
to stick to the formula of a three-act
structure that they could just show a
little bit of life being lived sometimes
just experiencing what somebody is going
through it's more exciting than being
told what they're going through you get
more sucked into a world when it feels
more real and reality doesn't always
have these three act structures or these
clever lines sometimes it's just a
little bit of life playing its way films
like Bambi Winnie the Pooh Christmas
Story the Sandlot they all knew that
and I think Kiki does too for me it was
the perfect little adventure that made
my appreciation of Miyazaki a lot bigger
[Music]
sometimes a movie needs a pig that is
the only reason I can think that they
actually put a pig as the main star of
Porco Rosso
a charming little film about a rogue
World War 1 veteran pilot who gets into
trouble flies around fights off debts as
well as air pirates comes across all
sorts of cool characters and is also a
pig and truth be told there is pretty
much no reason for him to be a pig I
mean don't get me wrong I know it's
symbolic it's a curse it's something
that he has to overcome but really if
you wrote that out it wouldn't make
little to no difference it's not like my
neighbor totoro or kiki where they can
do all sorts of cool big supernatural
things it's just he's a guy who happens
to be a pig I just don't get the point
of it the film is about a pilot under
the same name who's trying to make a
living but is constantly chased down by
people he owes money to he's constantly
relaxing at a hotel run by a friend
named Gina and is constantly being
bugged by an egotist named Curtis along
his travels he gets shot down and eats
his plane repaired by his ole mechanic
friend but he's not doing much work
anymore so he hands it off to his
daughter named vo skeptical for ability
she proves herself to be not only good
but downright brilliant at what she does
soon Porco starts to realize she has the
same diabolical brain that he does and
start working well off each other and
start planning ways to continue their
mischievous adventures but once Curtis
challenges him to one final duel they
make a deal if porca wins Curtis will
agree to pay off all of his debts but if
he loses Pheo throws herself in as the
prize and agrees to marry him will
Porco's confidence get him through or
will the demons of the past distract him
from the bigger goal in many respects
it's much more like the calmer Miyazaki
projects I mean true there is a lot
flying around and gunfire and stuff but
it's not for say a war or something on a
grand scale in Nautica it's more along
the lines of tailspin that kind of stuff
yeah there's violence but it's all kind
of place
the characters once again are all really
funny and really memorable the dubbing
is very well done with Michael Keaton as
the lead although not as sexy as that
American flag flies sharp but once again
I just don't get why this characters a
pig and the story he's cursed because he
fled away like a coward that's sort of a
debate at the end whether or not the
curse is actually lifted which I like
that but I why a pig could you do
something a lot more imaginative with
this couldn't be like a monster with
five arms and that way you can animate
them in a fun way
could you make him like a giant fly so
he can fly around already or couldn't
you do that I don't know what can you do
with a pig even the people around him
don't seem to care they're just like oh
yeah we know him he's a pig whatever and
like I said in most Miyazaki projects
that's part of the charm but here it
just doesn't seem to affect anything you
could just as easily have him be a
normal pilot with just a scar on his
hand or something like in Princess
Mononoke the only thing I can figure is
maybe they just wanted a little bit more
of an identity for the film like a
visual identity like you can look at the
poster and be like a pig fly wah I'll
believe that when pigs fly oh wait yeah
I guess that's the joke but it just kind
of seems like a middle that doesn't have
a whole bunch of possibilities either
making something really grand or crazy
or have what he's cursed with just
something very subtle but like I said
before that by no means makes it a bad
movie for all the dogfights a
machine-gun fire in this it's actually
very very relaxed it's just the
characters being really charming and
working off each other having pleasant
conversations the writing's decent dee
acting's decent it's all good I just
don't get the main creative choice but
maybe I don't need to because the film
is still a lot of fun regardless I don't
think I like it quite as much as Kiki
because like I said they do take more
advantage of the idea but still
enjoyable and we're seeing at least once
he'll the animation is so good maybe
it's evil we're seeing twice if you want
a film that has a little bit of
excitement a lot of humor but still at
its heart just kind of lay back this is
definitely a good one to check out
[Music]
[Applause]
by popular demand pom Poko I wish I had
a better excuse as to why I didn't
include this in the original Disney
cember but honestly I just forgot I
thought I had scheduled but then when I
looked over the list it looked like it
wasn't on there so I said okay we'll get
to it now the film itself is anything
but forgettable with a very distinct and
entertaining story pom Poko is about a
bunch of raccoons or tanukis who are
constantly fighting for their land that
is trying to be taken over by the humans
however the angle in this isn't quite as
dramatic as say Princess Mononoke it's
actually got a lot more comedy as more a
beat for the most part when you think
about bunch of raccoons trying to attack
humans you don't really think of that
much variety but again remember this is
Japanese lore and the tanukis could
shape-shift yeah remember a Mario 3 how
we could always turn to a statue in the
Tanooki suit well this is the same idea
the raccoons can not only turn into
people but they can also bend and shape
their body however they want the only
problem is a lot of them have forgotten
how and with the land constantly being
destroyed more and more every day they
send out to the elders to show them how
to do it once more the elders of course
teach them well and it's a constant
battle back and forth to see who can
keep the land and who's going to lose
it'd be much more comedic these
characters end up being very likable and
very funny it's almost like watching a
Looney Tunes cartoon just seeing these
big eyed fluffy animals constantly go
against people and allow them screaming
and yelling and running around flailing
their arms and making jokes back and
forth it always keeps the energy really
high but at the same time it has a lot
of character too you do get to know
these raccoons and their personalities
and you like how they work off each
other and how celebratory they are and
how they always get along for the most
part and they're always going on
adventures and you don't want to see
them lose their land the voice-acting
doesn't have this may celebrities as
much as natural voiceover artists like
trans McNeill Maurice LaMarche
but they do fit in a few names like
Jonathan Taylor Thomas and JK Simmons
and they all do fine for what's required
the only thing I might have a little bit
of an issue with is that there's a
surprisingly kind of high death toll
in this movie yeah it doesn't look like
it and in some ways the tone doesn't
even act like it but a lot of characters
die in this both people and raccoons
some have a heavy impact but others are
just kind of a glance in the sentence on
the one hand I say this kind of gets in
the way with the light-handed tone but
then on the other hand we don't really
question that much when we see storm
troopers falling to their deaths
constantly okay maybe a little bit of
dark reality can help - it doesn't
totally run the tone just once in a
while it's a touch distracting and oh
yeah let's talk about this elephant in
the room for anyone that has seen the
original Japanese version there's a
scene that you might find a little um
when they're finding out what their
bodies can do and what they can make
shape-shift they find out something very
bizarrely unique they can blow up their
genitalia to an incredible size yep
those big things that they're bouncing
off of that's supposed to be their
private parts um different cultures I
guess again on the one hand I can see a
bunch of kids laughing at this oh isn't
that funny they're using their private
parts and making the big TV ha ha but on
the other hand Jesus Christ they're
using their private parts now to be fair
they don't really look that much like
their private parts seeing how they're
playing with the size and shape and
everything but this is still kind of
up I remember why I saw this in
Japanese I said well there went the
chances for an English dub there but
nevertheless Disney still picked it up
so I remember thinking to myself how the
hell are they got tap-dance that little
bit well apparently in this version now
two new keys have pouches yep that's
their way around it and in all fairness
I don't think it's actually that bad
away around it I mean come on even
taking the Disney equation out of it
wouldn't you be a little uncomfortable
if American audiences saw raccoons using
their junk to fight people different
cultures I understand but as someone who
grew up in this culture yeah that would
never get a market and instead would be
replaced with a ton of angry parents so
I actually think it was a very clever
solution but whether they keep that in
or they don't it's still a very highly
entertaining movie most of it is just
watching them trying to stop the humans
from taking over the land and trying to
show the value of what they have very
simple but very effective and very funny
sometimes it gets a touch heavy-handed
like the main character
actually looks at the camera at the end
and speaks to the audience saying the
very obvious message but for the most
part it's just a really enjoyable
adventure with a ton of creativity and a
lot of imagination it's also nice to see
Studio Ghibli do kind of a different
story something that doesn't take place
in a fantasy world that has fantasy
characters and they're not human they're
all animals I don't really see that from
Ghibli to much where all the main
characters are animals
it's got good characters with a good
plot and a good moral it's definitely a
lot of fun to check out transform into
something that's fast and check it out
for yourself whispers of the heart
doesn't get a lot of attention but it
probably should because for what it is
it does it very well a coming-of-age
story about a girl learning about life
and romance and growing up and parents
and family and friends all that stuff
yeah I know what you're thinking haven't
we seen this a million other times and a
million other movies made for teenagers
and tweens and they're always done awful
and they're always super sappy and
cliched well well there are a few corny
moments here and there I think this is
actually a very well-done film that
really addresses the age I think it very
much shows the battle going out with a
lot of young people between their
passion and what they should most likely
do with their lives our main character
is names Shizuku she's a bookworm who
loves to write and discovers one day
that all her favorite books are checked
out by another person she starts to
daydream about who this person is but
then realizes it's a boy she can stand
over time of course they both start to
lower their defenses and they realize
they actually really like each other but
that's only one part of the story
another part involves her discovering
this antique shop were all sorts of
statues and beautiful items give her
ideas for stories she befriends the
owner and starts to find there's a real
magic to the place at least in a way
that inspires her imagination so much so
that she's now determined to become a
full-time writer even at her young age
she tells her parents she wants to drop
out of school and spend all her time
trying to write her perfect story the
parents respectful that she wants to
choose her own path
perhaps even a little too respectful
allow her to leave for a bit so she can
do exactly that yeah some would argue
not the best choice but then again she
does obviously learn her lesson and I
don't know it's a little controversial
but it's an interesting talking point
and once again that's kind of a very
simple story we're just following her
around seeing what her life is like as
she herself is trying to figure out what
her life is like where is she going what
does she want to do what's our destiny
what's her calling all that fun stuff
that teenagers ask themselves a million
times when they're younger the film has
a lot of charm and even a lot of drama
but as before there's not a ton of story
so again if this is something that
doesn't grab ya you can probably pick it
up very quick but I personally saw it as
one of those annoying teen rob stories
that were constantly advertised in
America in the early 2000s and hell even
nowadays I'm sure that's actually done
right and done with respect to its main
characters and just young people in
general
you kind of get sucked into her stories
you really enjoy her relationship with
the man who owns the shop you kind of
hope in a strange way maybe her and the
boyfriend can get together even though
they may not be perfect or maybe they
are perfect I don't know it's young love
and that's the point of it even the
corny scenes I mean like the really
corny scenes are still so damn likable
there's a scene where they're trying to
learn this American song and they're
trying to learn it in English which yeah
is a little weird with an American dub
but I think you can still catch on to
what they're doing and as they're trying
to sing the song all of a sudden all
these guys are just getting back from a
concert and they hear her singing so
what do they do they all go down and
they start playing with her oh my god
this is so silly and hokey but I can't
help it it's just so likable maybe it's
because the rest of the atmosphere of
the film is just so down to earth and so
mellow so that when something like this
happens that is pretty cheesy you kind
of accept it because it doesn't happen
that much in this film a kind of corny
moment can play okay as long as the rest
of it is mostly grounded in reality it
doesn't go for too many obvious labs or
to may traditionally dramatic moments it
instead tries to capture that
age when possibility starts to meet the
real world when dreams can be dashed but
what you discover that just means new
ones can open up the voice acting once
again is very nicely done I heard the
girls that were best friends in this
were actually best friends in real life
so they worked off each other much more
naturally they even got Cary Elwes for
this one throwaway role that actually
plays a bigger part in a later movie but
we'll get to that when we get to that
it's actually clever that they brought
him in for just a few lines but again I
can't say too much until we get to the
later film if I do have one problem with
the film is that the ending is really
sporadic out of nowhere and really fast
I mean there's like no lead-in to the
credit it's like somebody says a line
and then suddenly we're against these
pretty buildings with a nice song
playing with the credits rolling
there's no segue there's no fade to
black there's no nothing it just jumps
straight to it and yeah I gotta get the
idea what the final line it's puppy love
it's that age it's all about falling in
love at the certain point in time and
how you are and you rush into things
it's still weird but still the rest of
the film is really charming really nice
really laid-back I feel very much
captures an age that isn't life or death
but rather just discovery influence and
making mistakes here and there it's kind
of all those things you want to see in
those popular coming-of-age stories that
are also kind of corny but they're done
right it's soothing it's enjoyable and
it's definitely worth checking out
[Music]
it's what many consider Hayao Miyazaki's
grandest masterpiece Princess Mononoke
this was one of the first major releases
in America Miyazaki's work originally
under Miramax in getting one hell of a
cast to read of it Mononoke was the
highest-grossing film in Japan until
Titanic came along and that's how they
marketed it for a while what is in this
film I got so much of the Japanese
culture coming back to it going in I was
pretty hyped up and after it was done I
definitely liked it a lot maybe not to
the level everyone else liked it the
prints of a village named ashitaka tries
to stop a demon from attacking it after
his arm gets touched by the demon he
finds out that he's doomed to die
because meant at what pace will it
consume him and how much of its strength
will take that all depends on how much
he contained the part of the demon
that's forever gonna be inside him he
decides to set out on a quest - as he
puts it see you with eyes unclouded by
hate when he discovers as a war going on
between the human world and the world of
the forest filled with animals and gods
the humans want to make a prosperous
future for themselves while the animals
and the gods of the forest want them to
leave he comes across an industrial
leader voiced by Minnie Driver who wants
to cut off the head of the spirit of the
forest Allah have no more trouble from
them one of the forces greatest fighters
the queen of the wolves and her half
human half wolf daughter are at the
forefront of trying to stop her and
regain balance back to nature oh well ah
she talked I is caught in the middle not
knowing which side to choose and not
knowing which foe to fight the movie has
a lot going for it in fact I think you
could argue this is probably Miyazaki's
most adult work not just because of the
violence and gore though there is quite
a bit of it but because it's message is
not so obvious and blatant at least not
in terms of movies that died in the past
what's the route this could so easily go
the Fern Gully Dances with Wolves
Pocahontas avatar where the
humans are evil nature is good at the
end but one of the great things about
this film is that there is no real
villain even
the drivers character is very likeable
she's helping to cure the sick she's a
great motivator she brings people
together
she knows the tragedy of war and she
listens to the people who have lost so
much there's also other side characters
that could so easily just be seen as
villains but they put it very straight
forward that there are no real bad guys
in this world there's just people trying
to get what they can trying to survive
trying to be comfortable trying to be
prosperous it's a very human as well as
animalistic trait and that's part of
what makes it so clever it's showing
that the humans and the animals are very
much alike but not in the same way that
oh we shouldn't fight them because we're
so similar but in the way that this is
the reason why we're fighting because we
are too similar and we both want the
same thing lots of land and lots of
means to survive a very long time it's
funny because when I review Nausicaa a
lot of people were comparing it to this
movie like which one did it better which
one was stronger and a lot of people
seem to lean towards this one in a sense
I kind of agree I think this movie has
much better characters
I think its message is a little bit more
direct but it's also a little smarter it
ties in much more to what's happening
nowadays and will probably happen in the
future
where Nausicaa had this really big story
that went all over the place and could
kind of do it because it was so large
and scale Mononoke feels like a smaller
story yet kind of tries to do the same
thing it goes everywhere and back again
we cut back to so many of these same
locations like three or four times and
don't get me wrong I like these
locations but there's only so many times
I can see our main character walk back
and forth between them it was definitely
a film where before the climax I was
kind of looking at my watch saying huh
how long is this movie nothing I wasn't
enjoying it but I was definitely
noticing the length and definitely felt
it could have been cut at least 10-15
minutes just take out a couple more
scenes of him running to the other side
saying wait stop also as much as I love
the characters in this I do think
there's one that's surprisingly not very
interesting and believe it or not it's
Mononoke I don't think she's a very
interesting character and she should be
half human half wolf constantly torn
between what she is and who she's
supposed to be this should be great for
the
character they should be able to talk
and share stories and be able to relate
unbelievably they're both kind of going
through the same thing but most of her
dialogue voice by Claire Danes is mostly
gesture shouting no no I'm a wolf no no
I'm a wolf which is so strange because
Miyazaki is so good at these kind of
characters the young heroine who's
action-packed but doesn't know which
route to take he usually writes them so
well but this one is just so whiny I
have no idea why the film is named after
her it woulda been neat and she played
as big a part as I she taka it would
have been nice if she was just as
complex as he was but as is she just
didn't do anything for me I know that's
so weird because she's like the big icon
from the film but outside of her design
I think she's a real missed opportunity
but thankfully like I said before the
rest of the characters are very
interesting and their dilemmas are very
understandable and relatable this is
about the majesty of the forest and the
majesty of mankind both evolving too
fast for their own good and trying to
figure out where to level out I do
really like this film and there's even
elements of it I absolutely love I think
if it was just a bit shorter a little
less complicated and the Mononoke
character was made more interesting it
could have been something phenomenal at
least from my standpoint I know to a lot
of people this is phenomenal and I can
totally see why the voice acting the
imagination the writing it's a strong
piece I guess I just don't quite see it
as the masterpiece that everybody else
builds it up to be I do have issues with
it that hold me back from absolutely
adoring it but the stuff that's good
it's just too damn good to overlook
whether you love it like it think it's
mediocre or even don't like it at all
it's a good film to check out because
there's just too many interesting things
in it I can't see anybody going to see
this film and just saying there was
nothing to get out of it it's an
impressive feat and everybody should
check it out at some point I just can't
call it the Lawrence of Arabia of
animation like everybody else does but I
still think it's a pretty damn good
movie the animation alone is
breathtakingly impressive so go find a
copy give it a watch and see what all
the animation buffs are talking about
[Music]
it's no secret that Hollywood has been
out of original ideas for a while
everything is either based on a comic or
a book or a popular series or a TV show
everything is retro and based off of
something and well a lot of good stuff
has come from it it is kind of a shame
that we don't really see that much new
stuff coming out but then every once in
a while you get something as friggin
awesome as spirited away hands-down one
of my all-time favorite films this movie
has the creativity of all the great
trippy fairy tales Alice in Wonderland
labyrinth The Nightmare Before Christmas
so much of this really original stuff
that you just don't see that much
anymore I almost wonder if years later
they're gonna try and do a reboot of
this like a different interpretation the
world is so open the creatures so
strange it actually would kind of be fun
to see an artist different
interpretation of it
most people say you know something is a
masterpiece when you can't duplicate it
in a sense I kind of disagree
people say books like Peter Pan or
Christmas Carol are masterpieces but
we're constantly seeing different
versions of it all the time so many new
adaptations come out and I can see the
same thing happened with this it's a
world you're both delighted by and
horrified by at the same time you want
to live in it but you also kind of want
to run away from it in my opinion that's
the making of a great environment the
stories about a little girl and her
parents they're moving to a new
neighborhood they come across what they
think is an abandoned theme park but
really it's an enchanted bathhouse when
the Sun Goes Down and the lights come on
all sorts of various spirits come from
around the world to relax here this
terrifies our main character as she
finds out her parents have turned into
pigs and she also lives in the world
that absolutely hates humans but luckily
she befriends a boy who can thankfully
also turn into a dragon who decides he
wants to help her he introduces her to
the old lady who runs the place and
decides that she wants to stay alive
she'll have to get a job and the rest of
the film is heard just trying to survive
in this bizarre place while also trying
to make friends out of enemies who can
eventually help her get her parents back
the girl in this movie named Zen is very
identifiable she
is terrified of everything but so are we
we don't know what this world is and it
is really creepy
we see weird stuff happen like I said
her parents turned into pigs there's
monsters around every corner she has to
sneak around or else they'll kill her
but at the same time you start to enjoy
kind of the goofiness of it too there
are a lot of funny characters with
unbelievable designs this whole movie is
like a party house for imagination every
creature has their own unique look some
more human some more spider like some
more lizard like and the majority of
them have very distinct and likeable
personalities what I kind of like about
though is unlike something like Kiki or
my neighbor totoro they do put a little
bit more of a story to it there is still
goal that has to be accomplished by the
end of the film she has to escape and
save her parents but it's how she goes
through it that's the focus and what's
so entertaining she comes across so many
delightful people both delightful and
how charming they are or delightful and
how terrible they are some are even kind
of half in half and it's hard to get a
grasp on them like most of Miyazaki's
great work there is no one straight-up
villain there's just kind of rude people
kind of crazy people kind of sane people
it's just a wide variety the voice
acting once again pitch perfect that's
the same actress who voice lilo doing
the voice of Zen main what a talent she
gets every emotion you need to feel in
every scene she is frantic she is whiny
and she is a complainer but it's never
to a point where she's annoying you
totally understand what she's going
through hell you would probably do half
of this stuff too there's also so many
great side stories going on about
discovering people's past finding out
the flaws of these creatures and how
they can be helped out but even in
between all of that there can still be
moments of just relaxing and letting the
atmosphere sink in my god my favorite
scene is when they're on the train
nothing is happening here they're just
traveling and looking out the window but
after all the craziness that's happened
it's just the one place you want to be
there's no dialogue here there's no
talking whatsoever it's just them
looking out the window and you can feel
what they're going through this is the
power of a visual medium not everything
has to be spelled out a scene can just
play and you can take whatever you want
from it because you know there's such
talented people behind it talented
people that can make you feel afraid
one scene but delighted in the next if I
really had to nitpick anything I mean
friggin anything in this movie it's that
the owner of the shop also has a twin
sister they literally look exactly alike
even down to what they wear and with all
this creativity and different people and
creations why didn't you make her look
different
she doesn't have to be a twin sister I
mean okay there's one scene where she
kind of fools then but it wasn't
necessary you've got have made her more
beautiful or more ugly or just do
something a little different but like I
said before that's really scraping the
bottom of the barrel in terms of
nitpicking I've said before this is a
movie that's so good I'm actually kind
of jealous of it I wish I could come up
with something that's beautiful looking
I wish I could create these incredible
locations I wish I could come up with
such funny ideas to get rid of curses
and stuff like that it's kind of like
the imagination of a brilliant child but
brought to life by trilliant adults
these incredible animators and
phenomenal storytellers that just keep
you sucked in through the simple needs
of our main characters that anybody can
identify with and can identify with very
quickly being scared of a new place
trying to figure out your identity
having problems with family putting up
with people you don't like all these
things they're so quick to pick up and
it's all done in one of the most
incredible environments ever put on
screen I love this movie from beginning
to end it's just unbelievable the acting
the writing the storytelling and above
all the unbelievable imagination
everyone's praised the hell out of this
movie and I am one of the critics who's
just gonna do the same but it's just
that good I can't find that many things
wrong with it it's the exact kind of
movie I would want to see at any age one
that just engulfs me in its world I
don't even know what else to say about
it's just amazing pop it in your DVD
player and experience it for yourself
[Music]
so remember that story whispers of the
heart that the girl was writing about
this cat baron who could go into these
magical lands and had these great powers
well apparently the idea was so good
that they decided to make a movie out of
it
insert the cat returns a very confusing
title seeing how the cat isn't really
returning he's meeting this character
for the first time but whatever the
character he meets as a girl named her
room she saves a cat from danger in the
middle of the road but it looks like
that cat is a magical cat the prince of
a kingdom to be exact a kingdom ruled by
talking felines just like him
touched by his rescue he has her Ruis
she would marry him she's so dumbfounded
by what she's seen she doesn't know what
to say and he confuses it for a yes so
the king of the cats played by Tim Curry
demands as she be brought to the kingdom
and turned into a cat herself her only
salvation is a cat Baron played once
again by Cary Elwes who voiced the exact
same character in whispers of the heart
through all his magical antics and
mysterious ways he finds a way to get
her out of trouble as she gets back into
trouble and they constantly keep saving
each other back and forth and it's a
race to get home as also it's a
whimsical magic keeps taking place much
enchanted scenery is discovered which of
course leads to a lot of fun and some
fantastic imagery it's play that they
carry always to play this part because
it actually does sort of have a Princess
Bride feel to it not the story itself
but more kind of the feel it is kind of
funny and quirky but it's also kind of
like a fairy tale with magical lands
flying talking animals it's a really
charming setup a young Anne Hathaway
plays Haru and she does a wonderful job
actually playing it very similar to her
Princess Diaries character which I stand
by wouldn't be that bad a character she
was putting a better story this is that
better story
she is klutzy and awkward but she's also
kind of wide-eyed innocent and just
trying to make sense of a world that has
very little of it those of the voice
actors are great too Tim Curry puck you
go wrong
entertaining an officer whoever's next
better not see Peter Boyle as the Barons
sidekick
but there is one casting choice that
just boggles the hell out of me I first
saw this in the original Japanese
language and one of my favorite
characters was this cute little
assistant cat
you just saw her and you just wanted to
pinch her cheek she was so cute and she
had this little smile on this friendly
little voice she was just adorable but
then when the American dub came who did
they get to voice her excuse me but I
think there's a bit of a problem wait a
minute is that Andy Richter why is Andy
Richter doing what is still obviously a
female design
this isn't liking Kiki with Phil Hartman
where maybe it's male maybe it's female
you can't quite tell by the design this
is so clearly female every time I see
this character it's just so jarring to
instead not hear this cute little fluffy
voice and instead Conan's co-host
emergency exit brawl guest right here
his name's and don't get me wrong he
does fine it's just it's so clear this
isn't the right voice that should go
with this character it's kinda like
keeping the voice of the Little Mermaid
to a male baritone singer it just
doesn't add up
however the rest of the film is just a
pure delight it's not anything on an
epic scale like say Mononoke or Nausicaa
it's more like what the girl was riding
in whispers of the heart Oh cute little
fairy tale but it's cute little fairy
tales go it's very well done it's funny
it's imaginative it's clever
it has enjoyable characters and a lot of
wonderful visuals but hey why listen to
me talk about anymore see for yourself
and get whisked away
[Music]
if you see my nostalgic rave review of
pono you might remember a very
particular ending its Miyazaki it has
its own charm and it's just a lot of fun
not like that movie Howl's Moving Castle
since then so many people have asked me
why do I hate Howl's Moving Castle and
the first clarification is I don't hate
it I just don't think it's very good and
even by that I kind of mean by Miyazaki
standards it is still visually
interesting and has a lot of imagination
and it even has a fair amount of good
character what it doesn't have is focus
this movie is all over the place and
sure I'm not gonna act like story was
always the biggest part of a Miyazaki
film it was much more about environment
and characters and so on but there was
still enough of a simplicity to his work
that made it really come out as charming
this one just throws so much at you it's
hard to remember even what happened howl
in the movie is a wizard played by
Christian Bale he comes across a header
named Sophie who then comes across a
mean lady known as the Witch of the
waste it appears this witch is in love
with howl so much so that when Sophie
refuses to serve her she puts a terrible
curse on her transforming her eighteen
year old body into that of a 90 year old
woman determined to get the curse lifted
she sets out trying to find howl and
comes across what else is moving castle
well there she comes across some
colorful characters a scarecrow known as
turnip head Howl's apprentice named
Markel and a talking ball of fire voiced
by Billy Crystal she decides to appoint
herself the cleaning woman of the castle
because she sees it as such a mess the
bad news is it doesn't seem like he can
lift the curse
that's not especially on his mind anyway
as there's two warring countries and one
of them wants how to use his magic to
help them win their fight
owl goes back and forth between agreeing
to do it and not all while Sophie comes
across the evil witch who seems to be
losing her power and thus the curse
seems to be going away but only a little
and actually it's kind of inconsistent
sometimes she's older sometimes she's
younger I'm sure there's a reason why
but honestly this film goes all over the
place and tries to throw so much at you
that I guess it got lost in
me as a lot of this movie did I'm
constantly trying to remember what
exactly was I watched him what happened
in what order and what they meant and
where we were and it's just always doing
something I try to figure out why the
scatterbrain of a movie did so little
for me when something like spirited away
which you could argue also does a lot of
strange stuff and throws a lot at you
did so much the only thing I can figure
is movies like spirited away or Kiki or
Nausicaa is that they're fueled by very
simple desires sin just wants to save
her parents and leave Kiki wants to be
an accomplished adult Nausicaa just
wants to save her people here
I forget what Howells motivation is and
yeah I know Sophie wants to get the
curse lifted but even that's or it seems
like something that's put on the
backburner half the time with the other
films the ideas were motivating the
visuals here it feels like the visuals
are motivating the ideas I remember
there's a particularly strange scene
where Sophie and the witch are so slowly
going up these stairs and it's
uncomfortable and it's odd and it's not
pleasant to look at I remember asking
myself why am I even watching this how
is this enjoyable or dramatic or
creative it's just weird and unpleasant
that's not to say there aren't some good
moments the visuals for example are
great there's a really nice scene at the
end where she time travels for some
reason or other again it's really
complicated and hard to follow and it
creates almost kind of a dreamlike scene
I don't know it's hard to explain but
the colors and the atmosphere and the
mood it's the only time it felt like I
was genuinely watching a Miyazaki film
at least in terms of what it made me
feel the rest of the movie definitely
looks like a Miyazaki film and even has
some thoughts I can be izaki film but I
just didn't feel the same magic as other
Miyazaki films like I said I don't think
it's all fallen even people who asked me
why I didn't like the film kind of nod
and understand when I explain it even
the most die-hard Miyazaki fans don't
usually consider this one of his best
works it's still impressive and it's
animated great he'll even the voice
acting is still pretty well done but
it's not really one I look forward to
watching again when I had to do Disney
cember it has a nice artwork here and
there but for the most part it's just
kind of confusing and dull which is such
an odd thing to say
so much bizarre imagery but if you don't
care behind what's motivating it why
should I care to watch it to the end I
don't know if you enjoy it I understand
I'm not gonna act like there's nothing
to have fun with in this movie but for
me it's probably the only Miyazaki film
where the lack of focus actually got in
the way of it being a good product I
know I'm kind of a minority on that but
I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna say I
like something when I legitimately don't
but I'm not gonna act like it's anything
terrible either how much rather watch
the worse of Miyazaki than the best of
Michael Bay any day and I don't really
see this film as a waste of time there's
still some cool stuff to see but in
terms of getting some really emotional
magical moments
I'd say it's other work is more worth
checking out I know a lot of people like
it it's just not for me
[Music]
tales from Earthsea is based on the
series of novels that sadly I hadn't
read but based on the majority of the
film I've seen here I just may need to
it starts off with a ship of people that
look up and see a bunch of dragons
wrestling okay a strong start but this
news makes it back to the king of the
land saying that dragons never fight
that this is a horrible omen they talk
about how a lot of strange has been
going on like how Wizards have been
losing their power balance is being
thrown all over the place something bad
is coming something terrible and just
before they start to proceed forward to
figure out what to do about it
the king who seems like a pretty cool
nice character is killed I thought this
guy was gonna be the main character he
seems so nice and strong-willed but no
the kid that stabbed him is the main
character and on top of that he's the
son of this guy he steals the sword runs
away from the palace and the opening
credits roll holy that's the way to
start a story a million questions were
racing through my mind how is this the
main character what possessed him to
kill his father his father seemed pretty
cool
why are dragons fighting why is it bad
that they fight is that what dragons do
what place do they have in this
environment why is the Sun suddenly
normal now he seems afraid of these
wolves and like really creeped out
wasn't this the cycle that just killed
his dad a moment ago just oh my god it's
just racing through my head everyone
thinks you have to start off these epic
fantasies with these big battles or
explosions or something but in reality
all the great fantasy start off as
little stories they do this so you can
connect with the main character who's
usually somebody who's kind of timid
kind of afraid about to go on this big
adventure and that's exactly what this
movie does we get to know our main
character who is the prince
who's on the run from his heinous crime
and comes across a wizard played by
Timothy Dalton I'm convinced this guy is
Liam Neeson's monotone if it was made
more interesting just based on his
performance I would follow this guy
anywhere he's Stern and strict but he
definitely sounds like he knows what
he's talking about it doesn't sound like
a guy who's trying to sound bad as he
sounds legitimately badass along the way
they come across a girl with a burn mark
on her face she seems beyond socially
awkward and naturally the prince in her
don't get along but it also turns out
she's been adopted by this woman who's a
friend of the wizard or mage is there a
difference I don't know
gets a call mage slowly but surely they
start to open up and of course they find
out they have a lot in common and start
a nice relationship together but
troubles of ruin when another evil mage
named Cobb played by Willem Dafoe is one
of the few wizards who hasn't lost his
magic
thus he plans to use the imbalance
that's going on in the world to somehow
achieve eternal life and the mage seems
to be the ticket how along the way we
discover secrets magical powers and the
truth about what people's spirits as
well as their physical bodies are
capable of for the first two-thirds of
this movie I was absolutely in love
everyone always said this film was just
okay but I didn't know what they were
talking about I was sucked in I was
sucked in because I knew this was a
smaller story that was taking place in a
grander battle they kept talking about
how something big was coming some sort
of big change and there's just this
feeling of dread throughout the whole
thing it's kinda like in Game of Thrones
how when you get down to it there really
aren't that many big battles in it but
it's all about the bill up and
establishing the character well there's
not quite as much talk of strategy in
this there certainly is a feeling of a
lot of impending doom Cobb for example
is one of the creepiest villains Willem
Dafoe throughout almost the entire
performance does nothing but whisper his
lines and it is just unsettling his
voice is like a spider crawling its way
into your ear it's just so uncomfortable
whenever he speaks he's so hard to
figure out - I mean you know he's a bad
guy but always has this confident smile
on his face you know he can do these
terrible big things but he's also very
frail and moves very little you have no
idea what this guy is up to but you know
he has everything figured out and that's
one of the creepiest things about a
villain one that just has no fear
whatsoever so like I said watching this
film
I was just engrossed where was this all
going what's it building up to what's
the bigger grander picture that they're
finally gonna deliver but then when we
get to the third act I was really
disappointed instead of a big battle or
getting a bunch of answers or getting an
army together or just something that
seems larger it's just a small fight in
a castle with the hero wielding his
sword a few magic spells throne and just
fighting a great big monster while
trying to save the damsel in distress oh
man what a let
for a film that opens up with dragons
wrestling in so much dread and people
saying there's this great imbalance and
something terrible is coming this is
that terribleness that was coming I
totally accept the possibility that
maybe this is just the first part of the
story like maybe this is the Fellowship
of the Ring part and there's going to be
more to it but even in fellowship they
knew how to make a bigger deal of their
climax how to make you feel that this is
important stuff you're watching
ironically the problem I always have
with fellowship is that you never felt
the simpler side of it the normal quiet
life of our main character that's going
to be interrupted everything in
fellowship was big and huge even the
party they through this movie has the
exact opposite problem the simpler stuff
is there and is very well done and it
has some phenomenal build up for what
they could possibly deliver but in this
movie it never is delivered even the
ending kind of looks like they're done
and wrapping up speaking of which I
don't understand the ending at all
without giving away too much detail
there's another interaction with a
dragon kinda-sorta and I just don't get
it
it didn't seem like something that was
meant to be abstract or open to
interpretation it seemed to be like yeah
you're supposed to know what this is
you're supposed to know what's going on
and why it's going on the film is
directed not by Hayao Miyazaki but by
his son Goro and for a first film it's
really impressive like I said I love the
first two-thirds of this movie I don't
think I've ever been so hyped to see
where a fantasy film was going I really
thought this was gonna be like a Narnia
something that starts off so simple and
basic but turns into this grand epic
battle instead it feels more like the
last level in a Selda game even Willem
Dafoe seems to go from that terrifying
voice to something that seemed more
Green Goblin ish but still does that
mean I should dislike the entire movie
for that I don't think so I still love
the majority of this film if they ever
did make a sequel to it I probably watch
it in the hopes that actually does go
somewhere bigger like I said I even read
the books I have no idea how close it is
or far it is to it but for what it is I
really enjoy the journey I just didn't
enjoy where it ended up I'll emphasize
right now though that I'm one of those
people that just likes these kind of
stories the stories that start off small
and get bigger and bigger and bigger
for example I'm
of the few people that actually like the
first Hobbit I kind of felt like it was
the Fellowship of the Ring I never got
so I don't think this is a fantasy
that's going to engulf everybody hell
most people say it's okay at best but
personally I could get lost in this
world and its environment and watch
these characters all day yeah I know
this review is kind of all over the
place but hopefully you can get an idea
if this is something you'd be interested
in take your chances and see what you
discover
[Music]
Oh
it's almost kind of pointless to talk
about Pony Oh seeing how I've done a
whole entire nostalgic rate review
dedicated to it but let's take a quick
look anyway because this time we won't
have any jokes or anything just a
straightforward honest opinion the film
is very loosely based on the Little
Mermaid and when I say very loosely I
mean there's practically no reason to
connect it to the Little Mermaid it's a
female half-human half-fish that comes
out of the water befriends a male and
that's about it everything else is
completely 100% different it has less to
do with the lore I made then the Little
Mermaid Pony o is an enchanted fish who
comes from a magical man named Fujimoto
played by Liam Neeson one day she
decides to go exploring and comes across
a boy playing in the sea as she becomes
more and more human the boy in her start
to form a very strong relationship the
longer she stays human and out of the
sea the more it seems to throw the world
out of whack and I mean really out of
whack towns are suddenly put underwater
the moon is about to crash into the
earth it suddenly gets totally insane
but you almost 1 notice is seeing how
totally calm and relaxed everybody seems
to be no so their houses are underwater
big deal you know what it's good day for
a picnic let's row our boats go fishing
just totally have fun on this otherwise
beautiful day yeah
it's that kind of movie Kenpo neo get
back in time in order to set everything
right
well again being that kind of movie you
can probably guess what the outcomes
gonna be weird and that's definitely a
word to describe this movie weird it's
still charming and really likable but it
is weird if I think about is that even
though there is a lot of surreal imagery
that's not what's so strange about it
the strangeness really does just lie in
the story you couldn't predict the
reactions or the choices that these
characters make or the outcomes that
they produce on the one hand it's just
so strange to get a grasp on I mean it
seems like this is a tiny little story
about a girl befriending a boy and also
it's a little magic but then here talks
about the moon is gonna destroy the
world and it's like where
this come from but on the other hand
that's also what's kind of charmingly
strange about it it's basically in its
own strain setup where even if the world
seems to be under water it's kind of
okay something about that optimism is
very bizarrely likable the unexplainable
to say the least but still likable and I
think a lot just comes from its
simplicity all this chaos is constantly
going around these characters and yet
the biggest concern for our main lead is
to get ham yeah she discovers what ham
is and is totally obsessed with it how
can you not like a film so weird even
the art style seems a lot simpler
compared to other miyazaki movies but I
don't mean that any way to insult it I
think that's just the style it's drawn
much more like a kid's blog and it's
kind of told in that way too well for
the most part again the complications of
the plot are really I don't know I don't
want to say lazy but not really needed
but then again maybe that's the point of
it maybe it is meant to just exist in
this world where this extreme simplicity
in this extreme complicated batshit
insane plot can exist together and just
sort of create its own weird set up I
don't know if that necessarily makes a
classic but it definitely makes an
interesting experience and at the heart
of it is still some likable character
some enjoyable animation and a whole lot
of charm I really like watching this kid
and just how ambitious and excited she
is the tiniest things just get her going
nuts and yeah her happiness is kind of
contagious so does the film make a lot
of sense no but is it meant to probably
not the two words I constantly hear from
people in describing it is weird but
cute and I think that's sort of the
reaction I get out of it too it's crazy
but it's adorable it's all over the
place that's a lot of fun too I
definitely won't put up there with Kiki
or spirited away but it's definitely a
movie that's likable enough to put out a
few times take a look and experience the
madness for yourself
[Music]
The Secret World of Arrietty seems very
much returning to the form that films
like Kiki and Totoro did except in this
case they take the idea of a very small
story and literally make it a very small
story based on the book the borrower's
we follow the world of very tiny people
that live in a little house and how they
manage to get around without ever being
seen but our main character Arrietty
does get seen once coming across a boy
who apparently seems to be very slowly
dying he seems to have come to peace
with it and talks about his life with
her over time they find they have a lot
in common share a lot their experiences
and form a very strong friendship but
things start to get a little crazy when
one of the other people in the house
starts to think there are little people
that are roaming through the wood and
dedicates all of her time and effort to
finding out where once again that's
about all there is to the story but once
again that's about all that you need the
characters are all very likeable and all
very intelligent I really like hearing
the conversations that they share with
one another you really feel a sense of
family in this film a lot of films I see
that focus on family have a lot of jokes
and one-liners and put-downs and stuff
kind of like a sitcom here everyone
seems to talk like a real person the
only one who seems to speak differently
is the boy with the terminal illness but
that's a boy with a terminal illness
it's really fascinating to get inside
his mindset to hear how he sees the
world and how he feels so very small in
it which of course is very fitting
telling this to a very small person they
both have big worlds with big
limitations and yet for entirely
different reasons but even for all
they're talking there's still a lot of
visual imagination to this movie even
just them trying to get across the
kitchen is like this really big event
there's a great scene where they have to
do it at night and they have to be quiet
it's almost like watching an episode of
Mission Impossible it's just so
suspenseful and it's also great to see
just how they get through this world all
the little secret passages all the
devices that they make the engineering
even at such a small scale is very
impressive the only downside I have
which I'm starting to accept more and
more it's just sort of a criticism of
Japanese cinema I think is that the
ending once again seems a little rushed
at least in the placement of the credit
the movie seems to be building up to a
proper epilogue and then they just start
showing the names of everybody that's in
it doesn't it usually mean it's time to
get up and time to walk away I can't
really focus on what they're showing me
if I'm reading the people that worked on
the film and I really would like to have
been totally engrossed in that and just
watch that without a bunch of names
flashing in front of me I don't get the
creative choice but I can definitely say
it happens and a lot of animated films
from Japan maybe it's a creative style I
don't get but it does kind of bother me
but it in no way ruins the film this is
a really charming likable piece it's not
any huge epic but at the same time you
do really get sucked into a lot of their
problems you do kind of take a little
bit of a gasp whenever they're about to
be seen you do kind of become fearful
that they might get caught but at the
same time you enjoy the simpler moments
of them just sitting back and having a
conversation about the greater things as
well as the smaller things I really
liked it and I definitely enjoyed it
it's very laid back structure if you're
looking for big adventure you'll get
elements of it here there but it's
mostly a very calm subdued family film
but hey what the hell is wrong with that
give it a shot and see for yourself
a part of me says I should really hate
from up on poppy Hill like really hated
this is a phenomenally cliched story a
high school girl comes across a high
school boy who big shock don't get along
but the more they hang out the more they
realize maybe they can get along and
start to form a romantic connection but
once she shows that her father has died
in the war and he sees the picture guess
what by huge coincidence it looks like
her father was also his father and they
may be brother and sister even he
himself says it's kind of like a bad
melodrama frustrated by this they try to
figure out what they're supposed to do
while interacting with all sorts of
goofy characters and learning life
lessons and interacting with adults who
are sometimes right sometimes wrong
while constantly hearing the goofy music
that just celebrates a time of being
young yeah it sounds pretty standard and
done a million times and in many
respects it kind of is I was kind of
rolling my eyes that these are the turns
that this story is taking but at the
same time I did find myself kind of
wrapped up in it I think a lot of that
comes from not only the pacing in the
animation style which is beautiful to
look at but also some really damn good
voice acting I mean the voice acting in
the American dubs of the Ghibli films
have usually been spectacular and
Disney's done a wonderful job but this
one especially seems good because unlike
the other Ghibli films there's not a lot
of supernatural elements or magical
seams or weird angles or anything like
that it's just sort of straightforward
what you see is what you get
therefore the performances have to be
good or it's gonna lose you very quickly
I'm really amazed at not only how well
they match the lit movements but how
they keep the emotion of the characters
totally intact while doing so everybody
has a slip-up here or there even the
best actors but this one seems really on
track it seems to hit everything pitch
perfect another strong point is its side
stories which I get are a little cliched
but so much time is dedicated to them I
do find myself actually getting pretty
dumpin up for example there's a building
that holds a bunch of school clubs
that's going to be torn down all the
students inside most of the boys are
pissed off and constantly fighting to
keep it around however with the help of
our main character and her friends they
show that a big part is the appearance
and that if they clean it up get it
looking nice and stop being awkward
social shut-ins maybe they'll have a
better chance to save it at first I was
kind of annoyed at what cutouts a lot of
these boys seem like just the
traditional nerds and said traditional
nerdy things but after a while I really
didn't want to see that place go I
really found myself liking it
I even grew accustomed to some of these
oddballs even if they were kind of
cliched so on the one hand yeah it is
kind of a story that's been done a
million times the coming-of-age story
that's in the 60s and kind of American
Graffiti ish meets animal house ish
meets I don't know just a million other
movies you've seen before but I think
with a visual touch some really good
acting and some really decent pacing and
atmosphere it actually comes out okay
can you feel the manipulation when it's
going on absolutely but you can also
kind of feel the charm of it too slowly
over time I do still see a lot of major
problems with it especially with the
music that seems constantly on all the
time but even that starts to die down
after a while and you start to hear
these people for what they're really
saying and maybe you start to see the
movie for what it's really doing be a
charming little film that may have been
done a million times before but maybe
isn't trying to do anything that new
just try to do it in a way that standard
but charming at least charming enough
until you probably have to be pretty
forgiving in order to really get into
this film but if you lower down your
defenses a little bit it isn't half bad
not a great experience but not a harsh
one either if you're looking for a
romance that's standard but Pleasant
this isn't a bad one to check out
[Music]
let's finish off Disney cember with the
wind rises' Miyazaki's final film which
yeah he said a couple times before it
but hey Who am I to complain if he wants
to make more movies they're always great
as far as I know this is the first time
he's actually taken on a true story the
film centers around the life of a
designer who created the Japanese World
War two fighting planes many many people
would see this as a bad person but the
film makes it very clear that all he
wants to do is be innovative and pushed
the boundaries of what can be done with
technology it shown very clearly that
even from his youth all he's ever wanted
to do was push the envelope and the film
rather than focus on the controversies
of what it led to though don't get me
wrong it's not entirely ignored either
focus is instead on the innovation in
the imagination to bring these
incredible wonders to life in some
respects it's the most downplayed out
than Miyazaki films I mean there's not
really any monsters or moving castles or
anything like that he still finds a way
to incorporate so much beauty and so
much artistry into it for example he
constantly gets visits in his dreams
from his heroes great inventors and
creators who are constantly encouraging
him to try and find a way to make
himself even better he also comes across
a lot of places that happen to look
beautiful and even survives an
earthquake that as you imagine being a
Miyazaki film is pretty incredible to
watch again one of the charms of
Miyazaki is that you can be technically
not watching much just a guy working on
a plane or talking about ideas or
working with other people but there's
such a likeable ambition and atmosphere
and environment to all of it you want to
get to know these people you want to
help them with their planes and knowing
Miyazaki's love for gears and gadgets
this film has all sorts of that creating
building failing trying again and you
really admire this guy for having a
dream trying his damndest to follow it
all the way through even if in the end
it would amount to something horrible as
I said before the film doesn't ignore
the fact that this resulted in the
deaths of so many people there's
definitely people dropping hints about
the Nazi Party and what he's getting
involved in and
all the way through it he doesn't know
what to do he just wants to create he
wants to be the inventor I suppose a lot
of people could look at him as a bad
person for this but it's also kind of
like Einstein here's a guy who created
the atomic bomb one of the greatest
destroyers of human life yet we still
see him as a genius and there's
definitely people that don't like him
too because of that but there's no
denying that there's still a brilliant
mind at work that used a lot of
creativity imagination and determination
to do what they thought was going to be
a great thing and I think that's the
best thing to admire about this film the
ambition the ambition of the main
character the ambition of him trying to
get his ideas done and trying to do what
he loves to do there's a wonderful final
imagery of discussing with one of his
masters what he's done and what he's
created
it's a beautiful yet haunting landscape
of a bunch of people dead and plains
destroyed yet it's in this beautiful
green field of imagination and
possibility it's such a weird mix but
it's also the perfect bittersweet sum up
to everything this guy was working for
the problems I have with the film are
very minor
for example the romance in the film
though I don't know the real story about
it seems a touch forced he meets this
woman by accident during an earthquake
and then years later they happen to
stumble across each other again and even
without knowing each other very well
they decide to suddenly get married it's
almost something like out of a 40s
Disney fairy tale again I don't know if
that was intentional or if it was a
cultural thing but it was definitely a
little odd it's not that they have no
chemistry but for a film we know is
supposed to be based on real life it's a
touch distracting I also start to notice
things that I guess I never really
picked up from Miyazaki before that are
also a little weird like he never really
does sweating or crying correctly it
always kind of looks like they have some
sort of sickness plus I know this guy is
trying to be helpful and everything but
he scares the out of me something
about those eyes they just don't look
right it looks like some sort of weird
demon that I don't know could they have
fixed that up or something but aside
from that this film is very obviously a
romanticized version of true life events
yeah a lot of it technically happen but
it's pretty clear there is a lot of
creative liberties but never to a point
where it's insulting it's kind of like
tombstone they got the basic story in
people down
but yeah they obviously change stuff up
to make it flow a little nicer and be a
little bit more epic and you can usually
tell when those moments on earth I think
what impressed me most though is only in
the last 10 minutes was I starting to
get a little tired and saying to myself
I wonder how long this movie is but then
when I checked out and saw it was a
hundred and 26 minutes I couldn't
believe it only in the last few did I
realize how long it was and through the
rest of it I was just enjoying it so
much I can't believe a biography about a
guy making planes had me so invested and
so drawn in that I was actually willing
to sit there for a hundred 26 minutes
without even realizing I was sitting
there for that long if this did turn out
to be Miyazaki's last film it would
definitely be a good one to go out on
it's very clear he has this incredible
respect for someone that just wants to
follow his dreams and do something
incredible failing time after time but
still getting right back up to try again
much like Miyazaki it's a guy who loves
his work and loves doing beyond what he
thought he was capable of definitely
might push some people's sensibilities
the wrong way but I think the focus of
the film was to look at the power of
imagination and perseverance and hard
work and dedicating yourself to never
giving up and doing something incredible
and I can say that's definitely what
I've gotten out of the Studio Ghibli
films a world of imagination
entertainment and so much hard work that
went into it
so many of these films are classics in a
lot of people's eyes and they deserve to
be classics and even more people's eyes
people this dedicated hard-working and
are able to get their ideas to the big
screen should be celebrated as much as
possible so thank you so much for
joining me in this Disney cember like I
said before there are a couple popular
demands I'll throw in in January but for
the most part I wanna say thanks to you
guys for always making this such a fun
experience to put these together share
my opinions share yours as well
and keep talking about great artwork
that comes from great people keep alive
those great ideas determination artistry
and always allow great imagination to
take
[Music]
by popular demand the tale of Princess
Kaguya based on the famous Japanese
folktale that sadly I don't really know
so I'm not gonna be able to compare that
much what I do know though is that this
is a film that has a totally distinct
artistic style that is all its own it
has this incredible simplicity to its
technique which can often work in its
favor and other times possibly be a
little stale which is fitting because
the film itself kinda has that feel to
it but before you kill me let's go ahead
and actually look at the story a man
cutting bamboo in the forest subtly
comes across a baby inside one of the
trees at first she looks like royalty
but then she suddenly becomes a real
little kid he takes her home to his wife
and he's totally convinced that this is
a princess or at least that she's
supposed to grow up into a princess why
else would she look like royalty when
she was born convinced that her status
is going to mean everything the father
does everything he can to try and buy
her all the things he thinks she
deserves the mother is not as concerned
about her status as much as she just
grows up happy one minute she's a baby
the next day she's a little girl the
next possibly a teenager they're not
sure why this is but they try everything
in their power to not only love her but
also try to get a royal position which
Ellen Midd is a little confusing in this
world they sort of get her etiquette
lessons and get this really nice place
to live in but her parents aren't king
or queen so why would she be a princess
either way that doesn't seem to stop
them as they go around parading to
everybody that she has in fact a
princess
soon she starts getting all this
attention and all these suitors start
coming in but as par for the course she
doesn't really like being a princess
doesn't really like the suitors and is
constantly getting into trouble as time
goes on she does discover her real
origin and if I say anymore it would
kind of give things away let's just say
it's definitely more supernatural stuff
the best parts of the film are the
beginning and the ending the beginning
for the tight family connection and how
loveable they are working off each other
in the ending for it's a dreamlike
imagery as well as tone with sort of a
bittersweet send-off I dare say it's
almost
little too strange and how rushed it is
but it still leaves an interesting
feeling the middle is where it's the
toughest to get through one we've seen
all these cliches before the princess
who doesn't want to be a princess so
she's going to fight back and be
rebellious and all the people are gonna
tell her to be this other thing and yeah
yeah yeah seen it seen it not too much
that's new but on top of that it is just
so slow-moving there are so many moments
that drag on and on I remember thinking
to myself this should be over in a few
minutes why are we focusing 10 to 20
minutes on some of these subplots for
example she gives a challenge to each of
these three suitors that try to win her
hand they're all impossible challenges
but nevertheless all the suitors try and
accommodate anyway this should only take
out like 5-10 minutes of the film's time
but I think it goes on for something
like 20 or 25 I guess I just didn't
understand why these scenes were so
important I mean I love atmosphere you
see me praise movies like Kiki that have
very little going on but they're just so
likeable and they have such a world to
explore that yeah I absolutely love it
with this one though maybe because the
style is so simple you don't really feel
like you can get sucked in as much at
least not enough if you're going to work
with a very loose story the style itself
I'm gonna be very honest I was kind of
expecting a little bit more with for
example there's a scene where she really
gets her feelings hurt and she runs out
of the palace and all the Sun everything
goes really sketchy and it just looks
unbelievable this has inspired an
animation style that actually works
around the emotions of the character
holy smokes this is ingenious maybe the
more confident she feels the more
together and straight the lines will be
or the more she's falling apart the more
the animation will look more rugged and
sketchy and yeah holy smokes this is
almost like a totally new way to do
animation it could actually
revolutionize some things but that scene
where she runs out is literally only one
scene and it's at the most a minute long
why couldn't they do that throughout the
majority of the film I mean I know it
probably will cost a little bit more
money but it's already so simple anyway
why not go all the way with it but for
the most part it just sort of stays in
this one style and that's it what a
shame what a missed opportunity so die
just like the film I don't know if I can
say that I mean it was still so engaging
to watch and yeah was slow-moving but
still want to know where it was going
there are still a lot of scenes I have a
lot of imagination and sort of play with
tone a little bit almost like something
out of a dream but I don't know if I can
get behind it like a lot of other studio
ghibli's works I think I saw more
possibility that was tapped upon than
fully explored which isn't totally bad I
mean I'm glad something new was done
here I just wish you could have gone all
the way with it so again kind of a mixed
review but I would still lean towards
that is worth checking out because hey
it is still great artistry and it is
still a story that want to know by the
end what was going to happen take that
for what you will and decide for
yourself
[Music]
you